Identification. They say this session. Thirteen. Sorry session fourteen and this is the second side.
Coming up with fake panda invited if acacia. Well. Most history. Was Born. The youngest.
And she was nine years old she slipped on the arm of my mother she would out into the world with all the confidence one
could possibly. And. Like my mother she had absolutely beautiful. But we tried very hard to get her to study music.
She wouldn't have an inch of it too impatient. But she went around and she saying in different places.
And I remember one occasion the Polynesian club had a function in a hole in my happen. And so you must come.
So we went along. And they were everyone started clapping one tree me. Up Front.
And they put this roving marker of microphone. In her hand but she got the microphone like hanging behind a wife.
And she sings. She didn't need any market ever. Ever. It was just a natural just natural force. Any.
Now in eighty eighty. I had a yen and so I just went up to Qantas one day and I said I want to go.
And so I went off and she came out to see me off at the airport because she
and her husband were going to sue for they went to every year at Christmas time.
And she said to thought of coming with you. And so I said goodbye.
And I was I'd already been over there about four weeks and the phone rang.
I was staying here in bed and breakfast place and the phone rang and the woman said it's your husband.
And I was hands on hand said look I think you better come. Supporting the trouble is that Renie.
And he said yes and here's. And she said no she hospital.
And what had happened is that she went off to Fiji and she fell over on the dance floor one night
and a fractured skull.
And the superintendent of the hospital happened to be a friend who later became the prime minister.
Who was thrown out by the present prime minister room. And here come back to you with a plan.
She went into tonight's show and she never regained consciousness. I came back and she knew me.
But she was in no show for.
Six weeks and I said look it's impossible to believe they told me but I'm very good friend of ours PETER HARVEY The.
Physicians he'd been to see. And he said you could take some of your good tapes. And play them to her with a song.
So I went to my little type recorder. And I played her some of the songs she used. And she began to blink.
And that was you know she really went off with. I think beautiful memories. But that was a great.
I'm sure I can say that must have been the greatest loss.
I've ever had in my life and that was losing really we had no one for relationship. It was just great.
Anyhow I mean if it was a Kerry relationship. But with Reagan that was a lot of give and take and family.
That's how it was you were the two youngest two youngest. So. I spent four nearly five weeks in that.
And it was five weeks that I left because I was absolutely alone. I felt obliged to no one.
And I would just I stayed in two different places and I went for the breakfasts of course I couldn't face you know.
Two eggs and bacon and all that but so kind and generous terrible poverty.
It was like a Third World country in many ways dreadful poverty away from Dublin. But Dublin had it.
I found out had to take myself away from Dublin. So I went back to London and stayed overnight before I got the plane.
You know Qantas a real bastards to deal with they didn't want to. They said yes you can come and break her trip.
Agreement because it was a cheap plane. But she'll have to pay for it. So are said for sure.
I have to do that because I've got to get home and had it happen
and I said well they were under no obligation to replace it. So I point to my friend.
The lawyer as one of the for the attorney general. Franco.
And I said to George Look George this is happening what do I do. With your. Yes All right. Brilliant lawyer right now.
So here I have quarters and the check arrived I think about two or three days after. But you know I was unknowing.
To think I think that our airline would do that it was I was I mean it was one of the coasts. I thought.
Well I suppose in the seventy's something that also greatly was dismissal of the with them. Government.
I thought was a very exceptional person. It was the first time I think in the history of this country. That we.
A brilliant person for a prime minister. Like someone said to me you know what a bear to flee. Cheerfully.
Jessie Street took a deputation of upper middle class women to Canberra. To see chiefly.
To discuss the possibility of providing a child and to poor family. That was struggling.
That meant the money was for the children's education and so forth.
And it was called child in down mint and this way back in like thirty. Shortly after the war. That's right and.
Cheerfully was the prime minister because curtain. And she let this group of women up pretty well called.
A few people like that. And they were leaving office for a minute and said now. We must do something about.
The Aboriginal people out of the misery. And you know. You wouldn't Pakistan to marry one of them.
So as a Labor prime minister. I was overjoyed.
In fact I took a half a page in The Australian for an advertisement to help his campaign along.
And I did a bit of campaigning with Margaret. But he would intelligent people who were laid back. And I was so excited.
You know I. I could see that he we had a man who had vision certainly. I feel he should have taken a stand.
To Marie situation. And a few other things that I felt very sore about.
That he established the office for women's affairs.
And that was a good beginning and he never saw women as a threat at all and to this very day.
First of all or at a Human Rights Commission function
or where ever it is if the thing you have for your coffee for their coffee.
They never ever seem to expect any special treatment. No Margaret. I recall going to the north coast.
To treat AIDS to gatherings of my mother we were having a conference there.
And then they were closing down the conference early. And when I asked. Well.
Goff is overtly we want to get in here tonight. So I said Oh that's good. I'll go.
But actually it was in the morning the Sunday morning that he was speak in there and that helped prepare a lunch for.
All labor people. Not that it's maybe like the next World Cup.
And then I thought well I better get home because I still get to do. We tidying up for Kitty and so I thought.
I want to go off will get me a lease. So I said Can I have a lift back of course. So we got in his plane.
And on the way coming back.
He came up the back with the journalists who were and myself and his staff
and talked about the Harlan people because he'd seen so many of them there. And he said to me.
Well you know what you should form a national council. A National Party.
So you have to have a base to work from from for the for what is do you leave.
And so I came home and that's what I did in fact.
A few months later we formed the National Party for Australians are lenders. But that was what Gough could do and. So.
Sure he was tell me which Prime Minister was that bad. He was a person.
He didn't have that much compassion in the why that Keating. Intellect. He looked for. He didn't want to patch up.
And things must be changing legislation and then you know. It's a mentor. In the recent couple of my friends appears.
How do you feel about Diana going what was your opinion.
Well I personally think that she was a damn good woman who'd grown.
So where there was need to help and got in and helped.
I'm continued with a high life as well who would dispute that but she managed to organize that and I said good luck.
She's doing things. The same person said and what about Mother Teresa. And I didn't feel that way.
Personally of course I think I was a bit because she went to a conference in Dublin when I was there.
The last time I was there about three years ago.
And Mary Robinson the president was very taken back to research should be there if you police to support the right to
life and he to deprive women of the right of controlling their bodies. So you know my attitude was different.
There and apart from which I saw her more. As a political person show she said the hungry. She administered to that.
She taught others to do that which I thought was good.
There's a place for charity but somewhere along the line you've got to ask why. Why this difference.
Why there are six three. Well. And it's extreme poverty and if you carry any power as a public figure.
You have a duty to ask why why must it be like this. And I see Carol in this society.
A capitalist society many good things. It's very democracy. But there are a lot of things that need to be looked at.
We have many charities in Australia. And to few who are asking why is it for if that.
Further let this group of people must be disadvantaged. Why is it for ever.
That that group must be discriminated against and have to work. To remove discrimination.
And the work that goes into the charities is admirable.
But we should country like Australia make sure that that kind of work. To removing the cause.
So there is a need for charities but there's also a need to remove the causes of poverty disadvantage.
So this is going on recently and I had been thinking a lot about this
and said just to come back to the matter of the commission. I thought. It's a good. I felt. Right. Fulfillment.
It was given people a chance to begin a new life. We couldn't move in and help them. To think.
To perhaps change the thinking or their attitudes or anything like that. That's quite true.
But if it is some small why we help them to ask our. It may have helped. But it also gave children.
A beginning in life that they may not have. Any has so much the housing market with the Housing Commission. It was.
If you challenge. And satisfy. I think you leave it. They sure will.